Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Aujourd'hui, je réponds à une question que des millions d'enfants ont posée à leurs parents
et à laquelle ces derniers
n'ont pas toujours su répondre.
Comment on fait du lait ?
Allez, au boulot !
"À-Lait", c'est rigolo ça...
Tout commence dans un pré
où pousse de la bonne herbe, bien grasse...
Bon, celle-ci manque un peu de fraîcheur.
Et si on allait à la campagne ?
Dans un vrai pré ?
Une vraie ferme ?
Au milieu de vraies vaches?
Allez, c'est parti !
Elles sont belles,
ce sont des vaches laitières.
Il y a des prim'holsteins,
des jersiaises, des petites marrons.
Et il y a même une normande
au milieu du troupeau.
Ce sont elles qui produisent
le lait que l'on consomme le matin
et aussi celui avec lequel on fait du beurre,
de la crème fraîche, des yaourts
ou du camembert.
Elles adorent ces pâturages.
Normal, on est en Normandie.
Tiens d'ailleurs,
ça me rappelle une chanson :
"Les vaches rousses dans les champs, sur lesquelles tombe la pluie, et le bon cidre doux
made in Normandie".
La ferme !
Oui, je sais, on y va à la ferme,
mais avant, on en profite.
En France, il existe 17 races de vaches laitières
qui ont des noms adorables.
Il y a la bleue du Nord, la jersiaise, on l'a dit.
La montbéliarde, l'abondance,
la tarentaise, la Pie rouge,
la rouge flamande, la simmental.
J'en passe.
Et puis bien sûr, la prim'holstein
qui représente le plus gros troupeau.
Ces vaches produisent plus ou moins de lait,
un lait plus ou moins riche, plus ou moins gras.
Tout dépend ce que l'on fait avec.
On estime qu'une vache broute en moyenne
60 kilogrammes d'herbe fraîche par jour.
Et pas n'importe quelle herbe, elles adorent
le trèfle, la luzerne.
Mais ici, ce qu'elles préfèrent.
C'est le ray grass, quand elles sont
àl’étable, on leur donne du foin
ou de l'ensilage
que l'éleveur peut compléter
avec des céréales ou du soja.
Elles boivent aussi beaucoup,
de 70 à 100 litres d'eau par jour.
Alors évidemment, pour digérer
tout ça, il faut du temps.
On dit qu'elles ruminent, elles y consacrent
14h par jour,
un vrai boulot.
Et ça ne risque pas de faire tourner le lait ?
Pour le moment, c'est le système digestif
de la vache qui tourne à fond.
Je vais vous montrer.
Les vaches sont des ruminants,
leur système digestif
ne fonctionne pas comme le nôtre.
On dit souvent qu'elles ont 4 estomacs.
En fait, elles n'en ont qu'un, mais le travail est
prémâché, si je puis dire par 3 poches
qui se trouvent en amont.
Pour comprendre,
on va suivre le trajet d'une touffe d'herbe
dans le système digestif de la vache.
C'est un schéma bien sûr.
L'herbe broutée est grossièrement mâchée
et imbibée d'une grande
quantité de salive.
Elle est avalée et descend
le long de l'oesophage.
Elle stationne dans un premier
réservoir : le réseau.
Ça ne traîne pas, dès qu'il y a de la place à l'étage inférieur, l'herbe descend direction le rumen.
C'est ici que les choses
sérieuses commencent.
Cette poche fait environ 150 litres,
la taille d'une baignoire
en gros, l'herbe est prise d'assaut
par une armée de bactéries
et de champignons qui commencent
à dégrader les fibres végétales.
C'est un travail difficile, l'herbe remonte régulièrement
dans la bouche pour à nouveau être mâchée
et imbibé de salive.
J'ai compté.
La vache mâchouille une cinquantaine de fois avant d'avaler à nouveau la nourriture.
Et c'est cette activité que l'on appelle la rumination.
Tiens d'ailleurs, rumination, rumen,
c'est la même racine.
Elles mangent aussi les racines ?
Mais non ! Je parle de la racine
du mot, son étymologie.
Après plusieurs allers et retours,
le mélange se dirige vers le feuillet.
Désormais, il ne remontera plus à la surface, puis il passe
dans la caillette, le véritable estomac de la vache, ou la cellulose est dégradée.
Cette bouillie est ensuite évacué
dans l'intestin ou sont récupérées tous les éléments nutritifs.
Je ne vois toujours pas de vache à lait, moi.
Je vous le dis, ça tourne mal cette histoire.
Et la vache va bien utiliser ces éléments pour fabriquer du lait,
mais pour en produire, il faut un veau,
c'est la naissance du veau qui va déclencher
ce qu'on appelle la lactation.
Allez, on retourne à la ferme.
Dans les 12h qui suivent sa naissance,
le veau va boire le lait de sa mère.
Celui-ci, est né ce matin.
C'est un lait très riche qu'on appelle le colostrum.
Ce lait produit par la vache durant les premiers jours,
n'est pas consommée par les humains,
mais il est indispensable au veau pour qu'il fabrique ses défenses naturelles.
Et il en a bien besoin.
Ensuite, une petite semaine après
sa naissance, il est séparé de sa mère,
nourri au biberon avec son lait.
Puis peu à peu apprend à manger des aliments solides
comme de l'herbe et du fourrage
au milieu des autres veaux de la ferme
avec qui il grandit.
Et pendant ce temps,
la vache produit du lait.
Comment fait-elle?
La vache possède un pis et 4 mamelles
et non l'inverse qui se prolongent chacunes
vers un trayon.
Un, deux, trois, quatre.
D'où l'expression : "Se mélanger les trayons".
Euh, non, les crayons, je crois.
C'est une hormone qui déclenche la fabrication du lait, les cellules de chaque mamelle
utilisent les nutriments récupérés
dans l'herbe et véhiculée par le sang
pour fabriquer le précieux liquide,
elle se gorge de lait
comme une multitude de petites éponges.
Il est alors temps de traire la vache,
mais les mamelles ne libèrent
pas le lait sur demande.
C'est beaucoup plus délicat.
C'est encore une hormone
qui déclenche le mécanisme.
Quand on laisse faire la nature,
c'est le museau du veau qui,
en jouant avec le trayon,
déclenche la production de cette hormone.
L'ocytocine, celle de l'attachement.
Quand elle arrive au niveau
des cellules, elle déclenche à son tour
l'écoulement du lait
vers les trayons.
À l'étable, c'est l'éleveur qui,
en manipulant délicatement le trayon,
déclenche ce processus.
Oh ! Je crois que c'est l'heure de la traite.
On va aller voir comment
ça se passe en vrai.
Bonjour Antoine.
- Bonjour Jamy !
- Ça va ?
Ça va et toi?
Bon, elles n'ont pas l'air stressées ?
Non, elles sont à la cool.
C'est la traite, elles ont l'habitude matin et soir.
2 fois par jour, la traite.
Oui, tous les matins, tous les soirs,
tous les jours de l'année.
Alors comment on procède ?
Écoute, tu vas voir ça, je vais te montrer.
Il y a les vaches qui vont arriver.
On va les nettoyer, celles-là,
elles sont finies de traire et je les sors.
D'accord.
Alors, une fois qu'on a rentré les vaches,
je vais passer du savon sur les trayons.
Alors là, l'objectif c'est de débarrasser les trayons
des bactéries parce que lorsque le lait sort du pis,
il est parfaitement stérile.
Et donc là, on va nettoyer le trayon avec un papier, c'est un papier pour chaque vache.
En fait, on savonne ensuite un petit coup de gant, en quelque sorte.
C'est la toilette.
Exactement la toilette presque à sec
et on va poser la griffe.
C'est un drôle de nom, mais ça ne griffe pas du tout.
On l'appelle comme ça, juste à cause de sa forme, finalement.
Exactement, c'est juste là avec les manchons
qui vont à la fois aspirer et malaxer
le trayon pour permettre l'expulsion du lait
qui va passer, dans ce tuyau-là.
Alors la traite d'une vache dure entre 4 et 8 minutes
et chaque vache va fournir
entre 10 et 20 litres de lait par traite.
Et quand c'est terminé, et bien Antoine
dépose sur chaque trayon un produit
désinfectant et hydratant, car il faut en prendre très soin de ces petits trayons.
Effectivement, c'est un produit cosmétique pour hydrater et assouplir le trayon qui est
sollicité pendant la traite
et ensuite il y a une solution désinfectante
dedans, qui permet de protéger la mamelle
des microbes jusqu'à la traite d'après.
Le lait est stocké dans un réservoir en inox qu'on appelle un tank à lait, il passe en quelques minutes
de 40 degrés à 4 degrés.
Ceci pour être conservé dans de bonnes
conditions jusqu'à la collecte
qui a lieu tous les 2 jours.
Le jour de la collecte,
on prélève un échantillon, on l'analyse, puis le lait
est transporté jusqu'à la laiterie
ou il va subir d'autres contrôles
avant d'être conditionné
pour être vendu où transformé.
J'y goûterais bien quand même.
Antoine !
Et c'est le moment de la dégustation.
Donc là on a deux laits : jersiaise
et prim'holstein, qui est qui ?
Alors, je t'ai mis du lait de prim'holstein
dans ce verre-là et du lait
de jersiaise dans ce verre-là.
Goutte le premier et tu vas voir,
c'est ce qui ressemble
plus au lait classique.
Ça me rappelle le lait que je buvais dans
l'étable de mon grand-père
quand j'étais petit.
Ça fait des souvenirs.
C'est très bon, donc ça,
c'est le lait de prim'holstein.
Et maintenant, le lait de jersiaise.
Il y a déjà une différence à la couleur.
Oui. En ce moment, elles mangent de l'herbe
qui est riche en carotène.
Les jersiaises font un lait plus riche,
donc en fait, les éléments sont concentrés dedans
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il semble plus jaune.
Au goût aussi, il est plus fort.
Et oui, parce qu'enfaite les jersiaises font
moins de lait mais beaucoup plus riche.
Si tu veux le lait de prim'holstein,
il est à peu près à 4% de matière grasse
et celui de jersiaise à 6% de matière grasse.
Et aussi en matière protéique, il est plus riche en matières protéiques,
on fait plus de beurre et plus de fromage
avec un litre de lait de jersiaise
qu'avec un litre de lait
de prim'holstein.
Et de la crème fraîche aussi.
Et ça m'étonne pas parce que
“ça passe crème”, comme on dit.